[Music]
since leaving korean waters the nopets
have been conducting a number of trade
missions for oz
once again on the command bridge the
telegraph machine begins to receive a
message
we will receive five containers get them
to kourou
just over 24 hours later the nopak crew
are yet again conducting another trade
but this time with a russian cargo ship
five containers are craned onto the
copper field
their destination french guiana
the manifest states that the containers
are filled with sensaco gmo pineapples
which have a stable shelf life of up to
24 months
kevin thought this was pretty sus
why would the russians need no pets to
move fruit
yet when the containers landed on deck
they made a very distinctive clanging
sound
french guiana was easily one of the most
dangerous places on earth but regardless
three weeks later they were there
unloading and moving the cargo by rail
[Music]
the blackout of 2040 tipped the world
upside down and while everyone speaks
about the internet dropping off it was
the military implications that really
stirred things up
by having no spy satellites or feasible
ways to keep an eye on each other the
superpowers were growing paranoid and
placing huge importance on getting
hardware back up in the sky
the americans had lost the cape
canaveral space force station in florida
due to the rising sea levels
and rumors were starting to float around
about them turning to the old eu launch
site in koru
they would use this site to launch their
equipment into space
[Music]
however russia had obviously caught wind
of these rumors too and had been
encouraging uprisings against the
american presence in french guiana
specialist maria felk a former combat
medic
said sparking unrest is sort of russia's
specialty
and to be fair it doesn't take much to
get this place riled up
kevin could see by the look on her face
and the concern in her voice that she
was obviously a bit worried about what
was to come
a week later kavan and the no pets
arrived in koru
there they were to hand off the cargo to
the local militia
on arrival kevin noticed that all of
them were heavily armed with russian
weapons
one by one the containers were opened
and checked
cavend began to laugh as on opening the
first cargo doors revealed that they
were in fact pineapples
however after clearing these aside the
true intention of this delivery was made
known
the container was packed to the brim
with volkov multi-munition launchers
russian rocket launchers
but before anyone could say a word the
sound of gunfire began to echo around
them
and american troops started flooding
into the area
while trying to duck for cover kevin was
struck by a bullet causing him to
immediately pass out
by the time he'll work he was on the
back of a flatbed truck and escaping the
battlefield
his wounds were being tended to by maria
who was frantically wrapping bandages
around the gunshot wound to his abdomen
while fleeing the war zone kavan ended
up on board a ship that was heading
toward russia's oil station on
antarctica
with the rapidly rising sea levels by
2039 countries were finally starting to
understand the importance of leaving
antarctica and its ice alone
everyone except the russians
who in secret were violating the
international treaty that was protecting
the ice continent from drilling
eventually over time the remote science
facility located at queen moordland
quietly became a refining operation
responsible for up to four thousand
barrels of crude oil
daily
it was here that no pets from across the
globe would visit this area to refuel
however recently things were beginning
to change
as the fight for control and dominance
between russia and america continued to
grow
the superpowers were looking for ways in
which to bolster their influence
and now the oil was being cut off to the
no pets
the only way now to get it from this
facility is to swear allegiance to
russia
this was a price that oz is unwilling to
pay
now stranded on the continent with
nothing much to do
kevin stumbles across another nopat
specialist this one by the name of
constantine angel
whose own vessel has been stuck here for
three weeks
angel states that this is practically a
hostage situation and that ultimately
war is coming
it's only a matter of time until america
comes for this place
as more time passes
more and more nope vessels are winding
up stranded here debating the offer of
fuel for fealty
the cold in isolation is crippling
and many take the bargain
witness to this angel comments on how
short-sighted this is
that no pets shouldn't be choosing sides
he says to think of poland in world war
one their country hadn't been on the map
for 150 years
the polish legion did whatever for
whomever to make sure that when the dust
settled they still had a country
sometimes war is the only way home
kevin begins to recognize this rallying
called arms
it's something that oz has been saying
for a long time
and it ultimately works to keep his
notepads intact and on mission
suddenly loud falcons sound
and on the horizon a large american
destroyer can be seen making its way
towards the facility
this is quickly followed by the sound of
two large cannons being fired from the
shore
the american ship returns a warning shot
and over a loudspeaker a confident voice
orders the russians to stand down
the flag the ship is flying is the no
pet emblem
later kavan would find out that oz had
sent his most trusted captain to rescue
the stranded notepads before they
succumbed to the russian demands
kavan made his way aboard the ship along
with the other refugees
in his head eckhardt would angel had
said and all he could hear was those
words being repeated over and over again
there was a fight coming and it was
something he wanted no part in
yet there he was
stranded aboard a warship
maybe oz is right and war
is the only way home
the mfs-04 exodus is an ali burke class
destroyer under the command of a former
u.s marine
[Music]
cavern is in his barracks packing up his
things as the warship heads towards
freetown port
once there he plans on flying to cairo
and take up a position with sinsako
agrotex corporate communications
sinsakil were responsible for using a
private army to put a stop to riots
outside their walls last year
they were also the ones who provided
containers of pineapples that made a
clang sound
kavan has had enough
after 13 months of travelling around the
globe fearing for his life 24 hours a
day
he is ready to leave the notepads behind
he started this journey wanting to learn
more about them but not to die as one
and that this may be the last
opportunity he gets to leave
kevin's home is gone
taken by the sands
but egypt is one of the few countries to
come out on top during this time
in 2038 as traditional bread production
was failing sinsako agritech came up
with a two-part system to replace it
the first part included genetically
modified crops that were able to thrive
in dry and barren environments
the second part was a revolutionary
desert irrigation project
the reason since code decided that egypt
was the best place for this farm
was because of the nation's view on no
pets
egypt is the one place on earth where no
pack can lose the label and join a
country
provided they are willing to work behind
the wall
they have a home
this was kavan's plan
to take up work and leave the notepads
as they sail towards the african coast
he continues to think about the
conversation he had with angel
that the superpowers were already on
course for a war
if the 1.2 billion nopats were to get
involved it would only lead to more
strain on a world that has already had
enough
to make things worse the no pets are
clearly a fractured group with varying
agendas
a war within a war is looking to be the
most likely outcome
which would only prolong the inevitable
even further
by 6 30 pm the crew are finally able to
see freetown port on the horizon
currently only specialist rao is aware
of kavan's plans to disembark
but soon this wouldn't matter
the warship suddenly starts veering away
from the direction they were headed
taking a left turn they're now heading
north
[Music]
kavan can't believe his eyes
they were so close to the port
why have they suddenly changed course
where are they headed
he rushes to the bridge to find answers
when he gets there he sees a familiar
sight
an old telegraph machine much like the
one on the copper field
oz had sent new orders
before the captain slams the bridge door
closed caven hears one last thing coming
through the comms
we have one shot at a new future
and we're going to take it
[Music]
[Music]
you